[Music]
i actually think birds aren't real i'm
pretty sure they're drones i think they
charge on power lines like you would
never touch a power line right i
personally have never seen a baby pigeon
because i don't think there are baby
pigeons i think there's just you know
they don't grow i don't think birds
migrate i think that uh they take them
away and they they uh bring in the next
model kind of a thing that's the truth
you're in the city right and you see
all these uh houses right where people
live you see just as many birds as you
see people but you don't see a single
nest what's up with that the the scary
thing about the theory is like obviously
seagulls they have beach patrol right
they're watching the beaches uh the
pigeons watch the cities owls are for
night you know knife surveillance but
then we have other birds that we have no
idea what the government's using them
for like the flamingos you know what i
mean what in the world would the
government eat with a flamingo or an owl
or a penguin you know i think they're
just after world surveillance
all right
i'm go i'm on the air yes
okay it's this is a a complicated and
bad memory of way back in the 50s when i
was uh
in my early 20s
and back in those days they didn't have
birth control or anything like that and
i was living in greenwich village in new
york
and me and my friends were would get
pregnant all the time so we had we had a
place to go to up in harlem and we went
to this guy and we got abortions quite
frequently
and it lasted for i don't know a couple
of years i guess and then i moved on but
that was my embarrassing moment in my
life
okay so my secret is
i wish i was tall dark and handsome
and as you're about to see
i'm none of those
[Music]
i don't even know
where to start but
i just wish my dad
would reach out to me
[Music]
we never had a good relationship
and now we don't really talk and i wish
that he would reach out to me
because i don't know how to approach the
man that hurt me so much growing up
[Music]
um
for the past like
seven eight months i
have been in a kind of a dark place i
got comfortable with being uncomfortably
alone
and i would just kind of get
really high to just mask it all so i
didn't have to deal
with my feelings with my emotions
and
with that i
inadvertently
pushed away the best thing that's ever
been in my life
the person that i've never loved like
this before
and
[Music]
i honestly don't really know how to deal
with that
[Music]
i knew about my sister's drug use and i
didn't do enough to prevent her eventual
overdose
[Music]
i'm doing the worst that i have been in
my entire life but i'm taking it one
step at a time
and i'm dealing with it pretty decently
for how it is
[Music]
this is the happiest i have been in a
while
[Music]
my secret is that i
lie a lot but not to the people i love
just to complete strangers because
they don't need to know all that
[Music]
i've served five years in federal prison
for internationally distributing
methamphetamine
[Music]
so one time i was on judge judy for
crashing my mom's car and they kind of
made us lie to make it more interesting
[Music]
my secret is that i always say i don't
have a favorite niece but in reality my
favorite niece is olive
[Music]
when i was younger my best friend and i
used to kiss and chalk it up to
practicing for boys but i didn't realize
till later she was actually like my
first crush
[Music]
everybody thinks that i'm a very
optimistic positive person but i'm only
being positive to mask the discomfort of
my insecurities
and
my
inability to confront reality
my secret is that anytime i get mad
at my
ex-husband and the woman that he slept
with when we were married i go and egg
her car and i do it a lot
[Music]
my secret is that i grew up in a really
religious household and was very
sexually repressed for my whole
childhood so when i first had sex when i
was 23 years old and it was extremely
painful because i had
a condition called vaginismus which is
where psychologically your body tenses
up the muscles and it took me months to
work through it to actually be able to
have sex normally sex is hard for a lot
of women and i think vaginismus is
probably more common than i even have
thought that it is but we just don't
talk about women's sexuality a lot so i
think for anybody that is struggling
with these issues seeing a therapist is
really really helpful that's something
that i did that helped me a lot
[Music]
this one time when i was in high school
this one kid
always said the strangest
no one really knew what she was saying
until one day i decided to just
go and ask her
and she said she was practicing
hebrew to talk with her little brother
come to find out her little brother
passed away like
eight years
prior
so
i did what i could
help and i picked up a little as well
[Music]
so my deepest secret is i have a kid
um i haven't met him or her yet i would
really love to but the reason why i
haven't is
because it was really hard time with me
and my family if i would have told my
parents i would have gone kicked out and
the only people that know this are me my
best friend
and a lawyer who is trying to help me
locate my child whether it is a he or
she so yeah
[Music]
this is my darkest secret one day i was
working a brunch we did maybe 300 covers
and we were closed closed for brunch all
in then they said no
you have to make one more eggs benedict
and i'd thrown everything away and
in that moment
of being a young dumb cook
i scooped some of the hollandaise sauce
off the top of the trash
and i served it
but i promise it wasn't touching
anything i do feel bad though i'm sorry
everyone
[Music]
my secret is that even though i say i
don't want a big deal to be made about
my birthday friday i would really love
for everybody to make a big deal about
my birthday
[Music]
so my secret is i think it's so
unnecessary to make big deals of
birthdays thank god you got another year
with or without a huge deal
you are celebrated because you made it
another year
in my
okay my other secret is
i secretly love to speed on the
roadway i'm very cautious as a regular
driver but when i get a chance to hit
that hundred i do it
that's my secret hell no i don't believe
it you ain't hitting 100 and i work for
the court so
[Music]
i used to be a high school teacher with
keith smith school
and one night i was there late grading
and this guy came over and we made out
in the school office
the security guard caught us
[Music]
hey everyone for those of you who are
new my name is thoria and i'm the girl
behind the camera make sure to subscribe
and hit the notification bell so you'll
be notified every time i have a new
episode up and follow me on instagram
i'll be posting more on there as always
thank you guys for everything i love you
all and i'll see you next time